March is National nutrition month
according to the CDC 42 percent of U.S
adults are obese that can put them at
risk of heart disease diabetes and
stroke and fewer than 10 percent just 10
percent of Americans eat enough fruits
and veggies NFL star wide receiver
Devonte Smith helped take the
Philadelphia Eagles to the Super Bowl
this year and he takes his nutrition
very seriously Devonte Smith joins us
now along with sports nutritionist Kelly
Jones good morning to you both great to
have you here for having us so you know
we were just talking at the commercial
break Devante for you your food is your
fuel I mean your body is your temple in
what you do in sports what do you really
focus on to stay healthy
a lot of things you know that helps the
body you know recover and things like
that
um you know long days going to practice
and things like that you have to make
sure that you're learning the right
things recovery-wise also you know
nutrition
Kelly are there simple affordable ways
for us nine athletes to eat well and be
like athletes we do have to think about
that affordability Factor especially
with food costs going up recently and
you know my biggest recommendation is to
try to think about consuming especially
with that satin fruits and vegetables
consume fruits and vegetables in
whatever form is accessible to you it
doesn't have to be fresh all the time
those spoil more easily by the Frozen
even canned you know if it's packed in
water those can be easy ways too and
then prepping things on your own can be
helpful as well when you have the time
so we all have children under two at
this table and what do you what's the
advice for getting young children to
develop those healthy eating habits
especially for my grandmother but really
we want kids to feel confident about
food feel like they can make their own
choices so it's offering it in as many
different ways as possible putting on
the plate I know I hate food waste but
I'm always putting at least a little bit
on my kids plates I don't do the
sectioned out ones either so that they
see everything together it's there I say
no pressure you don't have to eat it but
it's going to be on your plate and you
know they eventually learn to taste new
things Devonte some younger athletes eat
terribly just awful like you see high
school athletes just pounding chips
before practice so what advice do you
have to them about how nutrition can
take down to the next level oh I mean
nutrition is everything to stay healthy
to continue to play the game that you
love to play um I mean if you're not
eating the right things sometimes it's
going to be hard to just go out there
and continue to do the things that you
need to do to get where you want to be
was there a moment was it was there a
moment you learned that and you had to
make a change yourself
um I would say probably my first year in
the league um you know I was always a
person that didn't believe in healthy
eating but um as I you know started
planning things like that body started
to feel a lot better when I started
changing the ways I eat
um I've seen that it makes a big
difference what do do you eat before a
big game like what is your go-to fuel
for
I'm I'm not a heavy eater before the
game I eat some fruit and just call it a
day really
all right so uh for youth athletes for
anybody looking for an edge what snack
is the snack of choice we talking apple
slices orange slices or banana so I'm a
big fan of banana banana is just going
to be more easily digestible it has a
little bit of fiber that's gonna you
know extend that energy apples can sit
in your stomach a little bit oranges are
preferred by some people too but
whatever is convenient for you and that
you can eat and feel good and trial and
error is really important so especially
with youth athletes as they're figuring
everything out it's try this before
practice how do you feel and you know
that's what you want to use game day or
whenever you're competing and it doesn't
have to always be fruits you know fruits
also for some people can cause some
digestive distress rate before exercise
so honey is an option there's other
package Sports Products obviously Honey
singer waffles are a cool thing because
they actually have fat in them too so
you don't get that blood sugar spike in
Crash and smoothies so smoothies same
thing you can add a little bit of fat
with peanut butter to that banana and
whatever yeah I know you're an orange
slices guy when you're talking earlier
there yeah that's key
all right Devonte Smith Kelly Jones
thank you very much for being uh here
that will do it for us if you had a big
plate of pancakes this morning you can
do better tomorrow
stay with us